[Musique]
une thrombose c'est un caillot de sang
qui se forment dans les veines la plus
souvent c'est au niveau des membres
inférieurs
ça se traduit par une douleur douleur au
mollet ou à la cuisse et par un oedème
sont les deux sites principaux se sont
pas des signes spécifiques
c'est à dire que c'est pas parce que
vous avez saisi de la cobp ligue at war
mans vous avez une thrombose ça peut
très bien être un problème musculaire ou
un problème rhumatologiques mais ce sont
des signes qui sont présents en cas de
thrombose veineuse
les sites liés à l'embolie pulmonaire
qui est la complication
là c'est une douleur dans la poitrine et
des difficultés à respirer
il peut arriver aussi que cette
thrombose ne donne pas de symptômes
c'est ce qui fait un peu son caractère
dangereux
c'est à dire qu'elle va pouvoir évoluer
progresser le caillot de sang se forme
dans une veine et il va monter
progressivement ou s'étendre s'il n'y a
pas de traitement ou s'il n'y a pas de
diagnostic dans les veines où on a vu ce
qui empêche le sang de renaissance
mais quelquefois selon certaines
circonstances il ya une chirurgie si un
cancer si on prend certains traitements
on va avoir ce qu'on appelle une star
c'est à dire que le sang circule très
très difficilement ce que le sang est un
peu et fc revient un peu à ça
l'incidence elle est aux alentours de 2
2 pour mille habitants par an
c'est vrai que dans certaines
populations exposées par exemple les
gens là j'ai quand on a plus de 75 ans
on est à 1 % et on a environ le tiers de
thrombose de phlébite tout membre des
flyers et un tiers d'embolie pulmonaire
en sachant que la deuxième est la
complication de la première
c'est une maladie qui est qui est assez
fréquente
on dit qu'elle est ubiquitaire c'est à
dire qu'elle va pouvoir toucher tout le
monde c'est plus souvent des patients
âgés
mais une fois qu'on le diagnostic est
fait quand on prend un traitement
anticoagulant
il n'y a pas de risque c'est à dire que
le caillot de sang ne va pas progressé
il ne va pas donner de complications
c'est des mains qui peuvent très bien
être traités en ambulatoire en externe
si la présentation de la maladie n'est
pas grave j'ai quelqu'un qui a par
exemple qui âgé qui a un cancer et qui a
on appelle ça un facteur de risque c'est
à dire qu'il favorise les thromboses qui
va persister ou si il y à une anomalie
de coagulation dans la famille là on va
pouvoir traiter plus longtemps et en
général on dit qu'on traite au long
cours c'est à dire au moins six mois et
après on continue à traiter
si le diagnostic n'est pas fait tout de
suite notamment s'il n'y a pas de
symptômes et que le vélo sans le tronc
bus progresse dans la veine à ce moment
là il peut se détacher aller dans la
circulation générale le coeur et elle
est bloquée dans les poumons et donner
une embolie pulmonaire
quelquefois ça peut être fatal mais dans
l'immense majorité des cas la thrombose
des prises à temps et avec un traitement
anticoagulant ça se passe très bien il
n'y a pas d'excès de thrombose celle que
l'on voit régulièrement ne sont pas en
excès liés à ces vaccins ce qui est en
excès c'est la présence d'une thrombose
tout à fait particulière qui est
probablement qu une thrombose associé à
une réaction immuno allergiques on me
dira une réaction inflammatoire par
excès liés à cette vaccination qui va
produire des anticorps qui vont eux
mêmes être à l'origine de la formation
d'un caillot de sang dans un vaisseau
donc soit dans une artère soit dans une
veine mais disons que ces formes là sont
paraissent un peu assez très différente
des thromboses que l'on voit
quotidiennement donc il n'ya pas lieu de
craindre
d'associations particulière avec la
thrombose standard je vais dire mais ces
formes là qui sont malheureusement
potentiellement très graves peuvent être
pourrait être relié à ce vaccin